since you seem to have more of a
business Acumen than I ever will I don't
but well I think you did you had to get
a real job for a minute been financing
well real the FBI would characterize it
as um a uh an issue but yeah yeah yeah
it's not yeah I mean everybody's a
Monday Morning Quarterback including the
feds
who do you think they you know they got
mortgages
but I mean many of the companies I work
for were rated good boy they were they
people did come in and want files Again
country of rats
I just love the idea of like you're such
an Irish guy that like just because I
had a suit on once you're like you went
you had a real job it's like I worked in
a subprime mortgage Boiler Room like
yeah he had a real job
your boss went to jail